El año que viene se celebran elecciones europeas.
Cada ciudadano VA a poder elegir a quién votar
entre todos los partidos políticos
que se presenten en cada país.
Pero habrá 1 partido al que se podrá votar
independientemente del país de la unión
en el que 1 viva
Raquel arciblo buenas noches,
Hola buenas noches. Es copresidenta de Bolt España.
Bolt es 1 partido que se presenta por toda Europa.
¿Correcto? ¿Qué es Bolt?
¿Explícanos qué es Bolt
vale Volta?
Es 1 partido pan europeo y también es 1 movimiento.
Tiene 1 doble alma siempre.
Esto me encanta decirlo,
tiene alma de ONG
porque la mayoría de nosotros y nosotras
somos millennial y queremos ver el impacto, ¿no?
¿También en el momento eh?
¿También
hemos tenido la suerte de poder viajar y trabajar
en la Unión Europea eh?
Y nos sentimos mucho más.
Ah bueno, cercanos no a personas de Francia,
de Alemania, de Inglaterra,
que no alguna vez no a nuestros vecinos de casa.
También es 1 partido político porque sabemos que eh
tenemos que estar en los lugares no de de poder
para poder cambiar las cosas
y 1 de los principales lugares de poder es a la
la Unión Europea. Somos